Hello! Welcome to Michael's Business Top Tips.
This month, we're looking at innovation for you.
How can you add innovation to your business?
Now, many people confuse innovation with invention.
Invention is much tougher.
That's coming up with some new, original product or technology or idea.
Innovation, in a way, is much easier.
It's looking at what is existing now...
...and how can we do it differently to make it better.
Two famous examples of this, Apple and Procter & Gamble.
First, Apple.
Apple is famous as one of the world's leading innovation companies.
And what they do is they take existing technology and ideas,...
...and make them better.
For example, the MP3 player, they made the iPod.
The mobile phone, they made the iPhone.
And now with e-readers, they're making the iPad.
All these ideas and technology existed before.
But they're taking a new way of doing it.
So think about this within your own business.
What could you do differently to make it better?
This could be product or service,...
...or just your daily routine work.
Second, Procter & Gamble.
Procter & Gamble took a new approach to R&D.
...by finding ideas for new products and drugs...
...outside their company, around the world, through the Internet.
By looking outside, they got a lot of new, original, innovative ideas.
Also, you can do this:...
...look outside your business.
Where can you get new ideas to change what you do?
One good resource is TED.com.
T E D.
This site is dedicated to spreading ideas...
...of new innovations in business around the world.
Check it out!
OK! That's it for today.
Remember, all of us must and should be innovators.
Thank you very much!